starting with the news that we heard
earlier in the programme that shell has
announced that it is pulling out of the
cambo oil field project saying that the
economic case for investment was just
not strong enough campaigners have
called it a death blow for cambo as the
project continues to lose support so is
this the clearest sign yet that fossil
fuels are falling out of favor and come
first to you
dame julia 30
of the investment has been pulled out 70
of it though is still there is it really
a death blow
well i'm hoping it is i'm hoping other
people will see that shell have done the
economic analysis and that if we're on a
path to no more than two degrees and
ideally 1.5 degrees
this just won't be profitable and and
really you know once we see industry
recognizing these things aren't going to
be profitable as we move to net zero
then
that's brilliant because that's what
will really drive change
and assad the shell says that this is an
economic decision do you think it is or
do you think it's political
well firstly i think it's a huge victory
for people power without the campaigners
we would not be in a situation where
shell was pulling out of this camper oil
field so of course the fight isn't won
the uk government can still approve the
oil field along with the countless
others that are in the pipeline but it
does give us hope and it shows us that
when citizens work together collectively
and put pressure on both these dirty
polluting companies as well as our
government we can begin to see an end to
fossil fuels sir because we've got to
remember what the climate scientists
have told us we have can have no new oil
gas or coal if we want to meet the 1.5
degree threshold which is critical to
prevent the runaway catastrophic climate
change that we are beginning to see all
over the world yeah that was the iea
report wasn't it and and dame julia uh
to you
if we accept that it is an economic
decision from shell what does it tell us
about the intentions of these big fossil
fuel companies is it the start of a big
shift
well i hope i hope that's what it's
showing us because we do need the skills
of these companies um we need their
skills for hydrogen production we need
their skills for carbon capture and
storage so if this is really the start
of of these of these
high carbon energy companies recognizing
that um that the economics have changed
and they've got to become green low
carbon energy companies then that's i'm
you know that's that's really brilliant
uh and that says it doesn't need it's it
doesn't matter whether governments say
we should support this or not if if the
companies have recognized the economics
of changes changed and that changes
their businesses then the change will
happen
yeah it's interesting to watch isn't it
and aside of course all of these big uh
projects very capital intensive they all
need a lot of money and what we learnt
in glasgow at cop26 is that 130 trillion
dollars worth assets under management
committed to net zero but that's only 40
of the world's asset under management so
60
of those assets are still happy as far
as we understand to invest in fossil
fuel projects
absolutely and uh and they're continuing
to invest in and the irony being that
some of those who are claiming that
they're going to be investing in in
renewable or clean energy are at the
same time pouring billions and billions
into dirty energy but look fix you know
the economic case uh one of the ways to
change that economic case of course is
fixing our tax system the uk has got a
very generous tax system to dirty energy
companies companies like shell for
example paid no tax last year in the uk
um we know that governments are handing
over something like 11 million dollars
per minute to dirty energy companies in
subsidies where
we're in trade deals like the energy
treaty charter which locks us into
decades of fossil fuels and even has
this thing called uh a corporate courts
investigate dispute settlement courts
which allows companies to sue
governments if they take actions that
threaten their profits these are all the
enabling systems that governments allow
and create which allow these fossil fuel
companies to operate i mean it's
in a ridiculous situation at the moment
where the netherlands the dutch
government is being sued for billions
because their government has planned to
phase out coal power power stations and
it's estimated that some of these
polluting companies are threatening to
sue governments for up to nine trillion
dollars in the coming years so really
you know it's government regulation and
government intervention